When I get a compiler runtime error, the first thing I do is likely look at the
screen and say, darn, it why isn't this right? But I move forward and the
second thing I do is tell myself, hey, you can fix this. You get this code, you
wrote this, you know where you can find the problem. So, I usually try to
comment out certain areas of code or build use cases for it to try to narrow it
down. And then, solve the issue within that one part of the code. The third
thing I do is I usually get really frustrated by that point, two or three hours
later, and I say, I can't do this anymore. Where do I go? So, I try to look at
some documentation or I try to look at some tips. And I specifically go and ask
some friends for help. The fourth thing that I do is usually I probably solve
it by then. So, I give myself a pat on the back and say hey, you can do it.
This is awesome. And I learn something, and I write it down. I take a mental
note of it so that next time I don't make that same mistake.